lon est en visio on vous voit bonjour à
vous bonjour et Nant est avec nous la
Loire Atlantique est en présentiel je
vais commencer par vous remercier de
votre présence nous excuser pour ce
retard à l'allumage on avait à faire à
des procureur qui étent
extrêmement prolix et intéressante dans
leurs interventions et donc ça n'excuse
pas mais ça explique et du coup je vais
vous proposer de passer une partie
formelle en vous demandant de la
prestation de serment qui requise devant
notre commission d'enquête parlementaire
vous savez que faut témoignage serait
possible de peine prévu aux articles 413
434-13-1-1 du code pénal et je vais vous
inviter chacun d'entre vous apprêter
serement de dire toute la vérité rien
que la vérité lever la main droite et
dire je le jure et vous pouvez le faire
tous en même
temps je le jure je le jure merci
beaucoup messieurs je vous propose que
sans désemparer on ouvre le débat je
sais pas qui qui de lesess sonne et la
Loire Atlantique commence des
communications écrites oui vous avez les
communications écrites très bien du coup
peut-être peut-être cont tenu du temps
qui nous est imparti et on vient de le
vivre là avec l'audition précédente
peut-être ne pas reprendre intégralement
les communications écrites en faire une
synthèse et puis ensuite on vous posera
un certain nombre de questions sur des
points d'intérêt particulier qui ont été
repérés par notre par notre commission
d'enquête vous avez répondu aux
questions qui vous ont été adressées
donc j'imagine qu'on aura pas mal
d'éléments en lisant vos
écrits
merci Nant
commence merci merci à
vous tout
d'abord merci monsieur le Président
merci messieurs les parlementaires je
vous présente Christophe Nico qui est le
chef de la division de la criminalité
organisée pardon je vous en prie
Christophe Nico qui est donc que mon
adjoint qui est chef commandant de
police chef de la division de la
criminalité organisée spécialisée euh au
sein du sipj de Nant service internal
interrégional pardon de police
judiciaire euh en ce qui concerne la
police judiciaire nantaise la
criminalité organisée à Nant est
caractérisée par une très forte emprise
territoriale des de clans de
narcotrafiquant euh au sein des
quartiers sensible de l'agglomération et
qui génère bien évidemment des guerres
de territoire violentes euh les
principaux points de vente sont la
plupart du temps partagés par des
familles issues des quartiers dont une
partie c'est exporté à l'étranger
essentiellement Espagne et Maroc le plus
souvent ces trafics de stup ont bien
évidemment généré des règlements de
compte qui se sont amplifiés avec le
temps qui trouve leur genèse en 2013 où
on assiste au premier règlement de
compte sur fond de trafic de stupéfiants
et ensuite les années suivantes ne vont
pas se démentir
puisque jusqu'en 2019 notamment qui a
été un peu l'année l'année de référence
pour
pour la criminalitéantaise avec 64 fait
de fusillad et de violence armé pour une
année et bon depuis une espèce de de
très légère apaisement de ces phénomènes
mais enfin on est quand même encore sur
des sur des tendances lourdes puisque
l'année 2003 c'est'est conclu avec 41
fait tout de même de de fusillad sur la
plaque nantaise
euh les trafics de stupéfiant évidemment
nonont évidemment pas faibli pour
l'année 2023 ce sont 840 5 kg de résine
de cannabis qui ont été saisies 436 kg
de cocaïne
et de façon plus anecdotique une dizaine
de kilos de
d'héroïne sur l'activité judiciaire
elle-même pour vous faire un petit focus
depuis 4 ans ce sont 413 mises en cause
en matière de stupéfiant près de 200
personnes écroué toujours dans le cadre
des trafic de stup
et avec comme je vous vous le disait une
connexité évidente de ces trafics de
stup avec les règlements de compte on
constate tout de même une évolution de
ce trafic de stup sur la plaque dantaise
avec 53 points d' référencé de façon sur
la Loire Atlantique une 30aine de façon
depuis 2 3 ans que carofast existe au
sein de de l'Office des stupes qui
permettent de référencer ses ses points
de deal on constate une généralisation
de de de la cocaïne désormais désormais
disponible sur l'ensemble des points d'î
avec une vraiment une démocratisation
très large de ce produit euh le cannabis
a toujours une part prignante également
euh phénomène également notable c'est
par rapport à ces points l'apparition
d'une main d'œuvre de plus en plus
composé d'étranger en situation
régulière on a une évolution très nette
après avoir été tenu par des
charbonneurs et ce qu'on appelle plus
classiquement des choufes euh qui
étaient des locaux sur ces points de
d'île on a vu une évolution ensuite on
est passé à une main d'œuvre euh
intérimaire qui été recruté via des via
des messages cryptés un peu partout en
France on a eu des phénomènes de
Parisiens des phénomène aussi de lillois
et désormais de façon de plus en plus
prignant ces points de d'il sont en tout
cas tenus par des étrangers en situation
irrégulière donc ça c'est un phénomène
qui qui a un peu tendance quand même à
se à généraliser sur sur Nant qui s'agve
qui se qui se développe d'ailleurs on a
pu le constater puisque à la fois comme
auteur et victime de règlement de compte
on avait très régulièrement donc des des
populations issues de des des pays très
majoritairement d'ailleurs des pays du
Maghreb et c'est une stratégie vouu
c'est une contrainte alors je pense que
c'est un peu des deux puisque en parlant
de stratégie c'est un intérêt commun
bien compris pour ces ESI c'est un
boulot c'est un job don bon étant donné
que la plupart d'entre eux ont quand
même vécu des choses un peu compliquées
avant d'arriver chez nous ils sont
souvent déjà ancré dans la délinquence
locale ils arrivent à Nant et c'est un
moyen de subsistance ça c'est la partie
leur intérêt à eux celui des trafiquants
il est bien évidemment encore plus
important puisque il y a une
méconnaissance totale de l'organisation
de la part de de de cette manœuvre là il
y a une méconnaissance totale des
visages du quartier des gens connus ou
pas connus et en plus du
reste de façon très cynique lorsqu'ils
sont victimes de règlement de compte ça
n'émeut pas grand monde voilà donc il y
a effectivement une espèce d'intérêt
bien compris réciproque voilà et
d'ailleurs on constate que de entre
guillemets main d'œuvre pas chè certains
prennent un peu parfois se sentent un
peu poussés des selles et décident deux
même de conquérir des territoires et de
passer à des étapes supérieures de dans
leur hiérarchie du
trafic euh autre évolution constaté
depuis depuis un petit peu moins d'une
dizaine d'années c'est l'apparition puis
l'évolution du rôle du port de Montoir
de Bretagne qui ne faut absolument pas
négliger dans le dans le dans le
panorama du trafic de stup avec depuis
euh 2019 environ des importations
importantes via le port de de Montoir un
peu à l'instar mais dans une bien
moindre mesure de ce qu'on a constaté et
ce qu'on constate au à dunkererque ou au
Havre avec des techniques de ripof qui
impliquent du personnel portuaire depuis
2018 ce sont pas moins de 16 dockers qui
avont été mis en cause dans le cadre de
dossier de trafic de stup d'importation
massive he puisqueà chaque fois ce sont
des dizaines voir des centaines de kilos
qui sont qui sont importés avec ce ce
procédé de ripof
on constate également une baisse une une
modification dans les dans les modes
d'importation alors la route demeure
aussi un vecteur important de la plaque
dantaise mais on constate de moins en
moins de convois comme on a l'habitude
de le voir de type goofast aujourd'hui
on est plus sur des des convois plus
discret dans plus petite quantité il y a
une espèce de de de fragmentation un peu
des trafics et alors on est on a moins
le phénomène de de grosses berlines qui
remontent l'autoroute qui viennent du
sud de l'Espagne et on constate
également une segmentation du trafic
avec un cloisonnement avec des équipes
dédiées qui seraient plus pour certaines
chcher chargé uniquement du convoyage
pour d'autres chargé de de de stocker la
marchandise à la frontière en attente
d'équipes souvent d'ailleurs originaires
de plusieurs régions donc là on a on a
ce phénomène là de de segmentation et
closonement des trafics on constate de
plus en plus l'utilisation de véhicules
aménagés avec des cash donc à la fois
pour descendre de l'argent ou
transporter de l'argent vers les vers
les clients et aussi pour remonter de la
marchandise
euh autre autre sujet également de entre
guillemets d'évolution c'est une
augmentation aussi de la vente de
stupéfiants par des via des messageries
des applications cryptées qui sont
devenus des véritables vitrines
numériques hein du du trafic de stup et
qui utiliseent au même titre que les
points de d hein des méthodes de
marketing publicité euh remise promo euh
sur euh pour pour doper les ventes enfin
euh
également mais ça concerne plus les
drogues de synthèse donc c'est un
phénomène sur lequel on est un peu moins
placé entre guillemets c'est
l'utilisation de plus en plus fréquente
des envoies postaux et des commandes via
le via le le
Darknet donc l'impact sur de de de ce
trafic de stup sur la criminalité
connexe ben je l'ai un petit peu
développé au départ ce qu'on constate
notamment sûrement c'est l'apparition
depuis une dizaine d'années maintenant
des homicides des tentatives d'homicide
par arme à feu on constate de plus en
plus une une
multiplicité de de de de ces règlements
de compte qui qui relève d'une part
d'une véritable désinhibition de l'usage
des armes on se rend compte que des
délinquants qui ont pas vraiment le
profil qui sont pas ancré dans la
délinquence lourde n'hésite pas pour
régler aujourd'hui des conflits
notamment pour conquérir reprendre ou
défendre des points de d'î à utiliser
des armes à feu voir des armes de guerre
très très fréquentes donc on a on a ce
ce phénomène là
euh qui
justement euh en parallèle de ces
phénomènes pardon on a aussi également
des des des opérations de rétention
violentes he contre les petites mains du
trafic dès lors que il puisse il peut y
avoir une espèce de de doute avéré ou
pas hein de détournement de produits ou
et cetera il y a phénomène de
séquestration
d'enlèvement d'usage de torture he on a
eu une affaire sordide en 2023 où où des
trafiquants de stup n'avaient pas hésité
à à à investir un appartement séquestrer
les locataires violer deux d'entre elles
et torturer pour récupérer une une dte
de 8000 € donc on passe véritablement on
a on passe un CAP en tout cas dans les
les mesures de rétorsion et
l'utilisation d'une d'une violence là
encore une fois
débridée
euh voilà pour ce qui est un peu
l'impact de la criminalité connexe on
pourrait également parler de blanchiment
on constate aussi un blanchiment de
Proxim ité qui est relativement
important avec
l'acquisition au-delà de de de
patrimoine immobilier dont ils savent
aujourd'hui qu'ils sont susceptibles
d'être d'être saisis mais en utilisant
des prênom l'achat de commerce de
proximité kebab chicha qui servent
également de de de
blanchisseuse vous nous aviez également
sollicité par rapport à au déport
éventuel de ces trafic vers les zone
rural alors c'est un phénomène que nous
on a effectivement constatéin on
constate pour pour divers raison il y a
évidemment une logique de marché tout
d'abord parce que au-delà de des trafics
urbain bah il y a une volonté d'ouvrir
aussi des débouchés pour ces trafiquants
qui sont de véritables chefs
d'entreprise avec des avantages des
inconvéent les avantages c'est que
effectivement là ils sont quand même
moins exposés à des règlements de compte
qu'en milieu urbain
euh ils peuvent effectivement générer
une offre qui n'était pas disponible et
donc générer une clientèle et en
parallèle de ça ça euh la contrepartie
c'est que c'est beaucoup moins visible
c'est beaucoup moins discret pardon
qu'en zone urbaine évidemment il est
plus difficile d'ouvrir un point de d à
Saint-Brévin Lespin que dans les
quartiers de Nantes donc il y a il y a
effectivement des avantages des
inconvénients la zone rurale reste tout
de même parfois une base de REP pas
forcément une zone de trafic mais pour
nos trafiquants euh où ils sont
évidemment peu connus et euh on a déjà
eu à traiter de d'opération de de réseau
de trafiquant de stup qui s'était donc
déporté sur la Vendé depuis la plaque
Lantaise
à la fois pour s'y mettre au vert mais
également pour y entretenir un trafic de
stup de proximité si je puis
dire les par particularités de notre
ressort et bien c'est un ressort
particulièrement attractif he pour les
trafiquants avec une agglomération de
650000 habitants qui est la plus grande
de tout le gare nord-ouest de la France
ça je ne vous apprends rien un
territoire attractif parce que
économiquement en croissance permanente
attractif démographiquement parlant avec
la présence également d'un gros pôle
universitaire des grands ensembles
urbains c'est également une situation
géographique attractive parce que une
desserte autoroutière importante vers la
Bretagne vers le Centre-Ouest et je l'ai
évoqué une zone portuaire très proche le
port de Montoir de Bretagne qui est à
côté de saint-nazer et qui luiême est en
relation avec les grands ports français
que ce soit saint nazer d'unkerer qui
avec des liaisons hebdomadaires avec la
Caraïbe dont on sait que c'est une porte
d'entrée importante du trafic de cocaïne
notamment sur vers le territoire
métropolitain
euh les moyens mis à disposition et bien
écoute la la police judiciaire de nante
dispose donc d'une d'un détachement au
faste qui compte 16 16 policiers ainsi
qu'une une cellule de renseignement
opérationnel sur les stupéfiants qui est
qui est pérenne qui est armée à TR trois
fonctionnaires dont un gendarme donc ça
ça ça a également permis de faire
énormément de lien avec les autres
services chargés de la lutte contre les
trafics ça a permis également de
cartographier les pointsil ça je vous
l'ai dit d'avoir une vision peut-être
sûrement un peu plus globale et
également au travers des de réunions
quasi mensuelles avec tous ces
partenaires d'échanger à la fois sur les
phénomènes que les uns et les autres
avaient relevé sur le ressort des
phénomènes nouveaux également sur nos
affaaires euh pour éviter évidemment
mais ça c'était presque le le but
initial qu'on travaille sur les mêmes
objectifs et et puis également surtout
surtout de faire du lien entre nous et
de découvrir quels étaient les les
acteurs de ce trafic et au travers de
cette communication de pouvoir être plus
efficace les uns avec les autres donc
cette crosse a été est opérationnelle
maintenant depuis 3 ans et elle a
désormais en plus en charge en parallèle
de de Laire Atlantique le territoire de
la Vendé puisque la la police judiciaire
de Nant est compétente à la fois sur la
Loire Atlantique et également sur la
Vendé
euh ça permet aussi une bonne
articulation je vous le disais avec les
services de la gendarmerie et de la
douane que vous dire d'autre les liens
avec le service de renseignement et ben
ils se font essentiellement comme je
viens de vous le dire en partie en tout
cas via la Cross qui permet ces échanges
fructueux on a également des échanges
très fructueux avec le renseignement
pénitentiaire qui constitue vraiment une
une une source très importante de
renseignement hein donc puisquon sait
aujourd'hui c'est pas je ne vous
apprendre rien en vous disant que
incarcéré ou
les têtes de réseau continuent à
alimenter leur
trafic et que au sein de de l'administ
des prisons parfois on a l'impression de
reconstituer des équipes qui avaient été
dissoutes entre guillemets à l'extérieur
donc c'est un phénomène qui perdure
c'est une réalité qu'il faut prendre en
compte et qui a été qui a été tout à
fait prise en compte par
l'administration pénitentire en mettant
en place ce service avec lequel on a
vraiment des échanges très intéressant
très fructueux et souvent qui nous
permettent parfois même de de
d'anticiper la sortie de ces de c'est
voyou
là on s'appuie aussi également sur des
notes de renseignement du renseignement
territorial qui dans le cadre de son
travail sur la mission de de mission de
sur les dérives urbaines et sur les
quartiers on parfois également de
l'information opérationnelle à nous
transmettre donc là encore des des des
échanges tout à fait fluides
euh pour terminer euh vous nous aviez
également sollicité pour savoir si on
avait des idées sur l'amélioration des
techniques des outils ou des pratiques
on en a identifié quelques-unes mais qui
sont je pense un peu sans Dre pour vous
des rodites notamment le développement
des enquêtes sous pseudo ça sur internet
ça peut être c'est un outil pour lequel
on doit reconnaître qu'on a des nous des
efforts à faire on a des outils on a des
personnels formés mais la charge est
lourde donc c'est vrai que on essaie de
prioriser ce en tout cas de de les
mettre en
place sur l'amélioration peut-être de
pratique on avait identifier euh la
porosité je viens de de l'évoquer à
demi- mot euh de la la prison par
rapport à à tous
les la disponibilité des téléphones
portables aujourd'hui l'intervention des
drones qui permet d'approvisionner euh
les les les personnes incarcérées bon il
y a toujours le le phénomène des
projections qui a toujours existé mais
en tout cas peut-être travailler sur la
possibilité de rendre encore plus un peu
plus étanche laincarcération de de ces
voyou dont on sait qu'ils ont encore une
influence très forte à la fois sur les
trafics mais aussi sur les règlements de
compte on a pu déterminer qu'il y avait
des ordres qui étaient donnés de
continuer à mettre la pression donc a il
y a une mise or d'état de nuire social
entre guillemets mais pas de mise or
d'état de nuire de trafiquant à
véritablement parl pour pour ainsi
dire voilà en quelques mots brosser le
panorama je ne sais pas si Monsieur Nico
vou rajouter quelque
chose je passe la parole du coup à à vos
collègues de lesson depuis la visio je
vous en prie monessieur monsieur le
président ent mesdames Messieurs les
parlementaires donc je compagnie du des
fourourn qui est le chef de la division
de la criminalité organisée et
spécialisée donc pour être synthétique
donc la particularité de l'esson est un
département donc de grande
couronne qui ce qui entraîne un C nom de
particularités notamment sur le fait que
le département est absolument pas
homogène vous avez tout le nord du
département c'est qui est celui qui est
le plus près de la petite couronne qui
est extrêmement urbanisé qui est une une
succession de de cités à coller les unes
aux autres et un sud du département qui
est beaucoup plus rural et qui était
essentiellement en dehors des temples
une une zone de gendarmerie euh la
proximité de la plaque parisienne a des
conséquences sur le sur le trafic pour
être synthétique et pour faire écho à ce
qui a déjà été dit sur les volumes si on
prend les saisies qui sont des saisies
de stup uniquement sur globalement sur
l'occupation de VO publ c'est 330 kg de
de cannabis dans dans l'année 10 kg de
cocaïne
environ en gros 1000 opérations de de
démantellement de point de stupéfiant
qui sont
euh référencé il y en a 90 en gros dans
le département euh c'est 3000 AFD à peu
près avec une particularité qui moi m'a
frappé je venais du Sud et notamment
j'ai beaucoup travaillé à Marseille où
le règlement de compte est un phénomène
extrêmement prignant euh dans en
Île-de-France et en particulier dans les
sones en dépit du trafic de stupéfiant
qui est quand même assez soutenu il n'y
a quasiment pas de règlement de compte
il y a de temps à autre des enlèvements
séquestration liés à des dettes
essentiellement euh mais très très peu
de règlement de compte en tout cas pas
de phénomène comme on le connaît dans le
sud comme celui décrit par mon collègue
dans anant donc ça c'est une réalité euh
qui est indéniable on a des structures
de de trafic qui sont très comparables
ce qu'on connaît ailleurs avec
effectivement des getteteurs des c'est
ceux qui approvisionnent des têtes de
réseau effectivement un phénomène qui a
été soulevé dans dans la question que
vous avez posé parce que ça part d'un
article qui qui avait mis en avant les
pratiques commerciales de de point de
ville de du valdiè valdesinene mais qui
est un phénomène en vérité qui est connu
depuis assez longtemps où en fait les
trafiquants bah qui se livrent une
concurrence alors parfois armée mais
c'est pas le cas encore une fois ici
mais en tout cas commercial euh et qui
rivalise en utilisant les les moyens
modernes des réseaux sociaux des forums
et ou de l'affichage pour vendre leurs
produits donc on on
a ici et c'est tout l'intérêtf on a une
cross qui fonctionne très bien et
notamment sur l'ensemble de la grande
couronne parce que effectivement il y a
une sorte de continuité criminelle
autour de de de Paris euh en au sein de
les on avait déjà une collaboration
extrêmement forte entre ce qui était à
l'époque encore la la PJ et la spéité
publique parce qu'il y a une vraie
continuité à avoir clairement dans les
trafics que ça soit en bas de la cage
d'immeuble jusqu'à au au tête de réseau
qui approvisionne le département euh la
la mise en place de la réforme de la
police nationale ne fait que renforcer
cette synergie qui qui existait déjà et
qui permet euh notamment monsieur
desfourneau qui est qui qui est le le
spécialiste et le reconnu sur la en
matière de lutte contre les stupéfiants
d'avoir une vue
complètement exhaustive de ce qui peut
se faire dans le département donc pour
pas alourdir le le débat enfin et et
pour répondre à la question que vous
posiez et qui pour nous est un un sujet
euh peu connu en vérité euh qui est du
transfert du trafic vers les zones
rurales la la distinction qui existe
dans ce département avec la zone
urbanisée proche de Paris et le la zone
rurale euh nous on peut pas dire qu'on
constate un un vrai transfert de trafic
vers cette zone rurale du département de
lesson parce que euh c'est pas la même
population c'est pas alors il a il y a
évidemment du trafic hein je je pense
pas qu'il y a de zones en France euh qui
soient épargné par ni la consommation et
donc le traffic de stupéfiants mais on
voit pas de phénomène massif si Disny de
temps à autre effectivement il en a eu
les gendarmes ont récemment fait une
opération avec laasr de Paris où ils ont
saisi 400 kg je crois dans un hangar en
zone gendarmerie parce que effectivement
comme c'est un peu plus isolé on c'est
plus facile d'aller cacher du produit on
avait fait à etamb qui est en zone
police mais dans le sud du département
une saisie de 60 kg de de résine et
d'Herb mais qui qui était juste un
échange c'est les trafiquants venaient
livrer là ils échangeaient et
repartaient ensuite pour servir le N le
département mais on peut pas à proos en
parler euh dire que nous constatons un
déport du trafic de stupéfiants
euh vers le vers les zones rurales enfin
nous on le constate pas en tout cas dans
notre
département voilà pour le le brosser
pour l'essentiel avec cette encore une
fois cette particulè on a la maison
d'arrêt de fleur Mogis qui est en zone
gendarmerie mais avec lesquell on
échange beaucoup euh sur le domaine des
stupéfiants parce qu'effectivement on a
quand même euh beaucoup de gens qui sont
incarcérés et on a beaucoup
d'informations qui remontent par là et
les échanges se font très bien euh
le on a c'est particulier à la grande
couronne la DR ce qui était la DRPJ de
Versailles maintenant qui qui est qui
qui a une vocation à prendre toutes les
affaires transversales ou en tout cas
venir en appui et qui touchent ensemble
dans la grande couronne parce qu'encore
une fois notamment avec les transports
en commun qui sont évidemment
extrêmement développés en région
parisienne on a des mouvements de de de
délinquent et c'est une délinquence qui
utilise ce réseau de transport soit pour
communiquer soit pour s'approvisionner
dans on en parlait tout à l'heure on en
parle longuement parce que c'est un
sujet majeur sur les les pistes de
réflexion et et ce vers enfin ce sur
quoi il y a sans doute des améliorations
majeures à apporter c'est aujourd'hui
c'est le l'utilisation par les
trafiquants du numérique c'estàd
qu'aujourd'hui c'est l'enjeu majeur euh
parce que les échanges se font
uniquement par des réseaux sociaux par
des boîtes cryptées par je des
conversations enfin sous le contrôle de
Christophe qui maîtrise ça mieux que moi
mais euh aujourd'hui les enfin les
conversations téléphoniques touchant au
trafic de stupéfiant c'est peut-être 5 %
des affaires et encore 5 % c'est les
vraiment ceux qui ont jamais qui sont no
vis dans le trafic euh le vrai sujet
aujourd'hui c'est de doter sans doute la
la la police des moyens nécessaires pour
investir l'espace numérique sur lequel
enfin duquel se serent l'ensemble des
criminels alors c'est c'est évidemment
vrai dans narcotrafic mais c'est pas
uniquement narcotrafic on a d'autres
criminel qui s'en
serent mais c'est vraiment un enjeu de
notre point de vue majeur et c'est
sensible dès le le premier niveau de
lutte de contre les stupéfiants c'estàd
dans les agglomérations de police ou Mme
Mme là les enquêteurs des unités qui
travaillent sur les stupéfiants avant
même qu'on on Vienne sur le haut du
spectre comme on dit
aujourd'hui ont besoin de pouvoir
intercepter ou en tout cas de de
s'insérer dans des forums ou des réseaux
numériques qui servent de base à tous
ces trafiquants voilà je veux pas être
trop long Christophe non TR
voilà d'autes question très bien moi
j'avais une une question que représente
pour vous monsieur Nico la
part des stupéfiants et dans vos
activités qui portent sur la criminalité
organisée et spécialisée c'est quelle
part à peu
près alors nous on est dcos Nant on a un
détachement au face donc automatiquement
on s'occupe d'affaires un petit peu
calibré on fait quelques affaires on va
dire n moyen importance on fait la
plupart du temps on c'est de faire des
dossiers de fond pour s'intéresser aux
équipes les plus calibrées qu'on a sur
notre ressort et on s'intéresse aussi de
façon un petit peu plus longue on va
dire sur l'activité du port de Montoir
de protetagne qui qui est une
problématique sur la région et au plan
national l'arrivée de la cocaïne par les
ports de commerce donc ça nous prend
beaucoup de temps on fait à l'occasion
aussi des affaires on va dire un peu de
moyenne intensité ça n permet peut-être
de de de de rester au contact de de la
délinquence organisée au niveau des
stupéfiants mais en tout cas on essaie
de calibrer et de travailler un petit
peu sur un tlon sur des équipes qui sont
un petit peu retaillées comme expliquéit
Monsieur le Directeur Départemental on
est confronté dans nos enquêtes à des
gens qui utilisent des messageries
crypté qui utilise qui mettent à leur
rtion tout avancé technologique donc ça
nous prend un peu plus de temps pour
travailler dessus ça nous laisse moins
de temps pour travailler sur une
intensité un peu plus basse mais en
Loire Atlantique la sécurité publique
s'occupe on va dire du pilonnage et du
démantelllement des points de Deal
auquel on on s'intéresse on est en
liaison avec eux pour voir si nous ça
peut nous apporter des ément sur des
enquêtes ou les soutenir des fois sur
sur sur des enquêtes par rapport à des
phénomènes particuliers pour qui pourrai
arriver ou des phénomènes nouveaux qui
pourraent arriver sur l'agglomération
Lantaise ou saint naazer aussi c'est
nzer aussi est une une agglomération
moyenne qui a quand même 13 points d'î
recensé et on sait que les stupéfiants
sur la façade atlantique au niveau de
saint-nazer est assez prignante aussi et
comme Anand des fois pèse un peu sur la
délinquence c'estàdire qu'on a h le
trafic de stupfion impact le travail de
l'eau face normalement au niveau de
l'activité de la brigade criminelle
cette année on a euh tr trois homicides
directement liés au trafic de stupéfiant
et 18 tentatives d'homicide paramainfeu
lié au stupéfiant qui nous engage à
faire des enquêtes criminelles à essayer
de remonter sur les équipes constitué
pour certaines qui ont commis ces actes
criminels et souvent on est lié à des
guerres de territoire avec derrière des
équipes et des donneurs d'ordre qu'il
faut qu'on retrouve et ça ça nous prend
beaucoup de temps donc pour le sipj44 on
passe beaucoup de temps sur le moyen
spectre ou le haut du spectre on n pas
le temps pour l'instant de de faire
autre chose ouis j'imagine et
vous avez utilisé à plusieurs reprises
le terme d'arme de
guerre quand vous parlez de terme en
terme d'armes de guerre vous parlez de
quoi exactement bah classiquement
malheureusement aujourd'hui de
kalashnikov de fusil d'assaut alors ça
c'est pour le la partie lourde sinon
très régulièrement ce sont des armes de
point 9 9
mm ce qu'on qualifie classiquement
d'armes de guerre et puis une dernière
question quels sont les liens que vous
entretenez avec les élus
avec le département avec la municipalité
et comment vous
jugez ces liens alors la police
judiciaire par définition on entretient
très peu puisque la plupart nos dossiers
sont couverts par le secret de
l'instruction donc on échange peu en
revanche dans le cadre de des échanges
entre guillemets plus traditionnel on a
des échanges avec la police municipale
par exemple parler avec des BA un outil
aujourd'hui qui nous a permis de
principal bailleurs sociaux voilà
essentiellement essentiellement voilà
parce que ils ont vraiment ce ce contact
fin notamment les bailleurs sociaux hein
les parfois ça débute par des histoires
de voisinage les histoires compliquées
d'expulsion et puis de fil en aiguille
les gens leur parlent pour se plaindre
de tel un tel voisin et puis ça nous
permet parfois d'identifier des
appartements nourrices ça nous permet de
de détecter des phénomènes qui sont
vraiment qui sont complètement en fait
intégrés dans le paysage urbain qui sont
finalement souvent par la menace
acceptée par les habitants parce que
faute de pouvoir faire autrement alors
quand c'est visible
ça se répand rapidement mais en tout cas
les appartements nourrces l'idée c'est
qu'il soit le plus discret possible et
parfois grâce à ces intermédiaires là
qui les habitants pourrai parler plus
facilement on obtient aussi ce genre
d'information donc c'est très important
de de travailler sur ce tissu
relationnel qui qui a notamment été
développé par les policiers de la Cross
44 quand votre collègue parle de
l'utilisation et de l'intelligence
artificielle ou de dispositif spécifique
pour surveiller les réseaux sociaux et
les communications cryptées quel quelle
est votre opinion sur ce sujetl pour
vous c'est quelque chose d'essentiel
essentiel alors dans le cadre de la
crimorga on utilise beaucoup de
techniques spéciales d'enquête hein nous
c'est vraiment aujourd'hui on a compris
que le téléphone classique à part nous
donner être une ligne de vie qui nous
permet de localiser parfois de savoir où
ils sont parfois ça nous malgré tout on
n'oublie pas que un téléphone son
utilisation ou sa non utilisation sont
parfois des des éléments d'enquête
intéressants par rapport à des habitudes
qui sont d'un coup bouleversé il a un
téléphone n'est plus du tout actif ou
alors qu'il est tout le temps c'est
aussi une indication pour nous un
téléphone qui bouge tout le temps qui
bouge plus c'est une indication pour
nous enfin en tout cas la vie d'un
téléphone malgré tout c'est important
c'est pour ça que on ne renonce pas non
plus à à brancher des téléphones même si
on sait qu'évidemment c'est pas en terme
de communication qu'on va apprendre
grand chose voilà c'est pas les
communications qui vont être très
enrichissante en
revanche les techniques spéciales
d'enquête nous permettent évidemment euh
de passer au-delà parfois des messages
cryptés et euh quand on y arrive B c'est
intéressant parce qu'évidemment la garde
est à ce momentlà baissé puisque le
sentiment de d'impunité ou en tout cas
de ne pas de ne pas pouvoir être entendu
euh permet de au voyou de de se livrer
plus à même sur leur activités et là
c'est souvent des sources très
intéressantes on l'a constaté mais ça
vous ça a déjà été évoqué dans les
précédentes auditions de cette
commission euh en ochat et skycc on pour
cela révél tout un pan du trafic de
stupéfiants tout un pan de la
criminalité organisée en Europe qu'on
soupçonnait pas ou en tout cas pas dans
cette intensité là et effectivement on
s'est rendu compte qu'à partir du moment
où il se retranch der des messages
récryptés ou dites inviolable et ben il
parle comme auparavant sur des lignes de
téléphone il y a encore 10 ou 15 ans
donc c'est
évident pour ça que c'est ce toutes ces
techniques spéciales d'enquête elles
sont extrêmement intéressantes elles
sont extrêmement importantes on peut
juste parf quit regretter
que on les dévoile trop facilement au
cours de nos enquêtes et quand il y a
des évolution majeure technologique
notre force c'est on a un petit coup
d'avance mais on sait que
malheureusement ça ne dure pas il y a un
débriefing qui se fait
entre équipe de voyou en prison j'ai
envie de dire il non que ça à faire que
d'éplucher les procédures de travailler
aussi voilà avec et puis bah au cours de
ces rétex puis qu'il faut les appeler
comme ça ben ils feront pas deux fois la
même erreur et donc notre peti en avance
il n'est que de courte durée
malheureusement ça nous oblige à une
adaptabilité permanente selon vous euh
la création de dossier coffre et la
protection de dossier coffre dans une
procédure c'est quelque chose
d'essentiel pour éviter que les
délinquants ne courent plus vite que
vous ça ça serait ça serait vraiment
important réponse et vous pouvez nous
citer un certain nombre de cas sur
lesquels la création d'un dossier coffre
vous aurez
euh mieux protégé dans vos enquêtes bah
en vous disant ça je suis obligé de vous
parler des techniques spéciales
d'enquête je sais pas si je je non
mais bah oui évidemment à partir du
moment où on accepte de et et c'est et
c'est la loi et il pas question de faire
autrement mais de solliciter des
autorisations pour l'installation de
telle ou telle technique d'enquête donc
forcément on explique malheureusement au
voyou quand il aura connaissance de la
procédure où est-ce qu' on a h pu avoir
accès à une faille dans dans son
organisation tout simplement et c'est
vrai que dans ses habitudes voilà nous
on se dévoile systématiquement que ce
soit sur la manière de d'installer ces
techniques d'enquête que qu' ce soit ces
techniques d'enquête elle-même c'est une
façon de oui on donne des bit à
l'adversaire
clairement vos collègues de lesson le
disaient de manière très claire vous
avez quelque chose à ajouter sur ce
sujetl et peut-être un avis sur le
dossier
coffre moi je juste une petite
remarque on a connu ça avec l'apparition
de la téléphonie mobile je m'en rappelle
très bien où dans un premier temps
certains opérateur pouvent être
intercepté d'autres pas et en fait c'est
une course on en parlait aussi tout à
l'heure aujourd'hui avec le numérique
c'est une course
permanente
à à l'innovation à la protection
supérieur ça fonctionne comme ça sur ça
on reviendra pas après donner des moyens
numériques enfin en terme de volume
d'effectif engagé dans cette lutte
contre
le en tout cas dans la recherche et
l'innovation quelque part si on prend
quelque chose de comparable dans le
privé c'est c'est de la recherche
l'innovation dans la lutte dans
l'utilisation contre
l'utilisation malveillante de de ces
moyen numérique sur les dossiers COF
Christophe je pense que ce sera plus
mais évidemment moins on en dira mieux
ce sera mais enfin le le le le principe
d'une démocratie est quand même de ce
point de vue-là euh incontestable
c'estàd qu'on on ne peut pas masquer la
manière dont on a enquêté donc il y a
bien un moment un avocat en aura
connaissance et par
définition les les voyaux en auront
connaissance également pour autant il
faut qu'on reste très pointu très
pertinent sur la recherche euh du moyen
pour avoir un petit coup d'avance sur
l'utilisation d'une technologie euh et
cette course ne s'arrêtera pas
c'estàdire que euh il y a 30 ans c'était
donc l'apparition de la téléphonie
mobile aujourd'hui ce sont les réseaux
internet et les réseaux sociaux hébergés
partout dans le monde avec des failles
de sécurité numérique qui sont
découvertes euh par ceux qui sont
chargés de ça et qui sont compensé par
d'autres ingénieurs et et et en fait
c'est une une but qu'il faut jamais
abandonner qui est pied à pied mais pour
ça il faut aussi engager des moyens
humains et financiers pour que nous
puissions conserver tout le temps ce
petit coup
d'avance après encore une
fois cacher la manière dont on a obtenu
une preuve c'est compliqué c'estàdire
que le notre système juridique ne le
permet pas c'est c'est au fond normal
euh mais il faut pas abandonner cette
lutte là et sachant qu'aujourd'hui pour
nous vraiment l'enjeu du numérique et de
l'utilisation qui en est fait c'est un
enjeu majeur et qui va pas se qui va pas
se modifier enfin en tout cas pas
ralentir dans les années qui
viennent le le président de la
République a annoncé hier une une
opération place net ou des opérations
placnet al sans vous mettre en
difficulté par rapport à les annonces
vous n'avez peut-être pas encore tout le
détail opérationnel estce est-ce que
c'est des initiatives qui sont de nature
à freiner le traficf comment vous
accueillez ça que c'est ch que vous
faites déjà d'une certaine manière ENF
commencer par les sones et puis
terminera par la Atlantique
oui oui alors les opération sont en fait
déjà mis en œuvre dans le département
depuis le mois de novembre
dernier d'ailleurs c'est une ement
d'ailleurs c'est une une approche qui
est assez globale c'estd qu' à la fois
un aspect investigation et à la fois une
occupation de terrain c'est extrêmement
pertinent parce que occuper le terrain
bon ça a beaucoup de vertus en réalité
d'abord pour la population qui subit les
trafics c'est quand même eux les
premiers
concernés cette occupation permet de
récolter de de l'information ça permet
également
de d'interpeller des les trafiquants euh
de de premier niveau vous parliez tout à
l'heure de de la relation avec les élus
locaux nous c'est une relation qu'on
tient de manière intense alors plutôt
effectivement à mon niveau ou celui des
chefs d'agglomération mais nous veillons
à ce que la la CRI la division de la
criminalité organisée spécialisée soit
destinataire des renseignements qui
transit par les élus locaux qui sont
quand même au au les premiers acteurs de
de la vie de la cité
et donc qui ont parfois des informations
particulièrement intéressantes donc
l'important c'est le lien que nous
entrenons ensemble pour utiliser C
information et les opérations place net
ont une un vrai impact je vous donner
les chiffres tout à l'heure qui sont des
des chiffres en fait de de saisie de de
stupéfiant sur le
terrain la multiplication des opérations
PL net vise aussi à ça c'està-dire qu'en
vérité ça nous permet d'être là où les
trafics se font de assurer la population
qui quand même en a bien besoin parce
que beaucoup sont victimes on le voit
d'ailleurs dans les les communications
qui ont été faites qui sont dans dans
les dossiers où on voit certains
trafiquants menacer des résidentses si
jamais ils collaborent avec la police
bon l'opération PL net c'est de notre
initiative c'est de la visibilité c'est
de l'interpellation immédiate donc oui
tout ce qui sera occupation de VO public
enfin c'est un évidemment il y a
l'aspect investigation qui est
fondamental hein sur lequel on
évidemment ninterpelle pas de trafiquant
mais les les deux vont vont ensemble
c'est dans ce sens-là que que nous
travaillons avec à la fois le les trois
niveaux de de l'investigation mais
également l'occupation de de la voie
publique pas grandchose à rajouter
monsieur le Président seulement
qu'effectivement elles sont on les
adosse à des à des opérations
judiciaires d'envergure en général et
c'est ce qui nous permet en plus de
bénéficier de de cet appui au moment de
des interpell puisque il y a
effectivement un certain nombre de force
c'est souvent enfin c'est ce sont dans
des quartiers qui parfois sont un peu
délicat à travailler pour des unités
plus réduites là ça permet d'avoir une
grosse visibilité également he ça
rejoint ce qui avait été dit
précédemment vis-à-vis de la population
qui a quand même le sentiment parfois
aussi d'être un petit peu seul par même
si il y a une forte occupation du
terrain par nos collègues de de en
uniforme il y a une véritable politique
tout à l'heure Christophe Nico parlait
de pilonnage des points d' c'est ça
c'est c'est véritablement du du si on
doit employer un mot à la mode même s'il
est un peu dévié de c'est du harcèlement
l'idée étant effectivement de ne pas les
lâcher et donc la finalité c'est presque
l'aboutissement ça débouche pour sur une
opération d'envergure adosser un trafic
plus important et désormais qualifié
d'opération plnet ouais donc ça regroupe
ce qui vient d'être dit
effectivement on sait aujourd'hui que en
France grosso modo le produit du trafic
qui s'établit entre 4 et 6 milliards
d'euros tout ça au doigt mouillés c'est
peut-être même un peu plus que cela
et à la
base ce trafic il s'alimente par de la
consommation quotidienne donc des
petites
coupures de de l'argent liquide qui
circule et qui ensuite va être collectée
va être stockée va être blanchi et on
est frappé de constater le peu de moyens
qui sont donnés dans les procédures
d'investigation à l'aspect patrimonial
du trafic à cette conversion à ce
blanchiment qu'est-ce que vous pouvez
nous dire sur ce sujet-l est-ce que vous
pouvez nous faire quelques suggestions
pour être clair vous faites une enquête
vous apercevez qu'il y a des quantités
de stupéfiants importantes vous imaginez
que ça a généré un chiffre d'affaires de
temps et que ce chiffre d'affaires
aujourd'hui il se matérialise par des
petites coupures par
de l'argent liquide
et est-ce que vous estimez avoir les
moyens suffisants pour rechercher cet
argent et est-ce que vous avez des
suggestions à formuler pour
l'amélioration de cette recherche
alors de façon assez classique en police
judiciaire si je puis dire tous nos
dossiers de stup sont adossés un dossier
de de recherche des avoirs criminels
c'est systématique systématiquement il y
a ce qu'on app un fond de l'œil
financier on a la la chance de
bénéficier d'un agent des impôts
permanent au sein de la police
judiciaire de lant qui fait toutes les
investigations nécessaires le recherche
de patrimoine l'idée étant évidemment de
de saisir le maximum d'avoir criminel
qui se traduisent la plupart du temps
évidemment par l'argent qui sera saisi
sur place mais également on va très loin
dans dans cette recherche là puisque on
va aller jusqu'à rechercher de la
maroquinerie évidemment des bijoux euh
des voitures et et et des biens
immobiliers immobilier euh la difficulté
étant c'est que au même titre que pour
les que pour les nouvelles technologies
les trafiquants nous pas nous ont pas
attendu pour s'adapter la plupart
d'entre eux ne disposent même plus de
véhicules à leur nom aujourd'hui il y a
beaucoup de véhicules en leasing de
souslocation de véhicules immatriculés
en Pologne ou en Allemagne he c'est des
phénomènes qu'on qu'on constate très
régulièrement pour ce qui reste de
l'argent liquide on a aussi et on l'a
constater dans plusieurs dossiers he le
phénomène des sarafes avec l'exportation
entre guillemets en tout cas la le
déplacement très régulier de grosse
sommes d'argent à destination de
d'intermédiaire qui eux-mêmes vont
remettre ça soit dans l'économie légale
soit la le faire partir dans les pays
d'origine donc et puis un investissement
très très limité sur le territoire
national aujourd'hui ce sont souvent et
là je parle entre guillemets
d'expérience parce que on a aussi la
chance d'avoir un GIR alors qui est un
GIR gendarmerie en l'l mais peu importe
on travaille aussi main dans la main
avec le GIR sur tous ces dossiers
stupéfiants et eux développent des
enquêtes à l'internationale très
fréquentes il parviennent à des belles
saisies immobilières notamment que ce
soit en pardon en Espagne ou au Maroc
donc on a quand même on a jamais lâché
ce ce terrain là de la recherche de la
saisie des des avoirs criminels c'est
d'ailleurs un des objectifs he qu'on se
fixe chaque année la police judiciaire
et et la police nationale sont sont les
les les plus gros pourvoyeurs de ces
saisi d'avoir criminel en France donc
chaque service est vraiment engagé dans
dans cette lutte là avec Ben nous des
moyens comme je vous le disais un agent
des impôts on a une collaborateur qui
s'occupe exclusivement de monter les
dossiers à destination de la justice
pour préparer les saisies et les
confiscations parce que saisir c'est une
chose confisquer c'est encore mieux sans
perdre de vue aussi que parfois nous en
sommes les bénéficiire puisqu'on arrive
à se faire affecter des véhicules je
trouve que en la matière c'est un cercle
vertueux de réutiliser et de remettre
dans le dans le les mains de la police
ou de la gendarmerie les véhicules
fruduusement acquis et voilà on en
bénéficie de de façon très régulière
mais tout ça a pris beaucoup de temps
vous le savez ça a été un long chemin je
pense que la route est encore
longue la route est droite mais la pente
est raide en la matière en tout cas et
de nouveau il faut qu'on soit encore
ingénieux plus inventifs pour essayer
encore de contourner développer encore
la coopération internationale on sait là
encore que
nos collègues de la division des
relations internationales travaille
beaucoup sur cet axe là sur les
partenariats on sait qu'il y a des pays
avec lesquel il est beaucoup plus
difficile
d'obtenir d'obtenir un résultat et euh
bah nos voyou ne s'y sont pas trompés
hein et ils savent effectivement ils se
renseignent ils savent où est-ce qu'il
faut placer de l'argent où est-ce qu'il
est plus difficile pour nous de de
récupérer c'est le fruit de leurs
activité criminelle mais en tout cas on
y travaille on c'est un un plan
d'activité qu'on a jamais lâché et sur
lequel on est et on est particulièrement
attentif et sur la le secteur de NES on
constate une augmentation de ces saisies
Contu de l'augmentation du trafic c'est
corrélé en matière de stup pour ce qui
est des saisies numéraires on est à peu
près constant c'est-à-dire on est autour
de 600000 entre 600 et 650000 € par an à
peu près ce qui est pas énorme au regard
des chiffres que vous avez annoncé et ce
qui est pas énorme par rapport à ce
qu'on a
constaté dans un dossier qu'on a traité
en 2023 où on avait pu constater qu'en 6
8 mois plusieurs millions d'euros avait
été avait été transporté vers des
sarafes l'idée étant pour nous
évidemment si on avait plus on a trouvé
beaucoup d'argent mais pas pas autant
bien évidemment mais par rapport au flux
financier c'est peu évidemment on s'en
satisfait pas même si c'est toujours une
satisfaction mais encore une fois il
faut pas oublier non plus que dans le
cadre de de leuringénosité un certain
nombre de ces boyaux sont déjà passés
aussi à la cryptoonnaie et donc là c'est
de la monnaie invisible c'est de
l'argent qui n'apparaît nulle part si on
tombe pas sur le Wallet et si on a pas
le code on en fera rien et de plus en
plus alors pas immédiatement sur le
deuxième niveau du trafic de stup mais
dès qu'on passe un certain stade on se
rend compte que là encore il n'ont pas
laissé passer des opportunités ils se
sont intéressés à la matière et pour eux
c'est une source évidente facile
d'évasion monétaire ça prendre pas de
place à une époque on parlait beaucoup
du problème des gros trafiquants qui
savent plus quoi faire de l'ARG argent
parce que ça prenait une place dingue là
aujourd'hui ils ont réussi à réduire ça
à la portion conru ça se déplace
facilement et ça se dissimule dans
n'importe quoi nous on a énormément
sensibilisé nos enquêteurs dans le cadre
des perquisitions pour chercher tous les
supports qui
pourraient qui pourraient donc contenir
des wallettes des clés USB puisque on
sait qu'aujourd'hui on peut les mettre
sur quasiment n'importe quel support et
il y a une recherche aussi de la même
façon qu'on recherche l'argent on
recherche aussi évidemment ces wallettes
qui sont aujourd'hui une façon
d'échapper à nos saisis euh très
ingénieuse pour les sones vous avez des
observations sur ce sujetl la saisie des
avoir la confiscation la saisie pour les
son c'est comme M dit mon collègue de
Nantes nous on a systématiquement un
service financier qui travaille avec
nous on a le J 91 aussi qui est associé
à la majorité de nos dossiers donc
patrimoine est fait quasiment
automatiquement sur chaque dossier
effectivement la plupart des délinquants
ne mettent plus rien du tout tout à leur
nom ni véhicule ni appartement euh on a
constaté même un développement de de
délinquants qui se qui maintenant sont
spécialisés dans le fait de prendre à
leur propre nom euh des logements qui
vont ensuite redonner ou revendre aux
délinquants euh au délinquants euh
stupéfiant euh ce qui fait que ni
l'appartement ni les abonnements ni le
tout ce qui concerne l'abonnement EDF
l'abonnement téléphonique né au nom euh
du gérant de trafic euh ensuite il y a
effectivement tout ce qui va concerner
euh les avoirs à l'étranger ça on en a
énormément on a fait énormément de
dossiers avec des euh des
investissements faits à Dubaï fait au
Maroc euh récemment au Sénégal avec des
achats d'immeubles avec des achats de
villas avec des achats de de véhicules
euh et là c'estil y a que la coopération
internationale qui nous permet
effectivement de pouvoir saisir et là
tout dépend des pays euh dans lequel on
peut euh bah on peut intervenir et
d'autres malheureusement sont beaucoup
moins coopératifs euh et en ce qui
concerneargent liquide alors
effectivement dans le trafic il y en a
énormément euh vous imaginez bien que
ils ont déjà beaucoup de mal à faire à
faire passer l'information de savoir où
est le stupéfiant alors l'argent c'est
encore beaucoup plus caché que que le
les produits stupéfiants euh ça n'a pas
empêché qu'on ait réalisé quand même
quelques belles saisies sur ces
dernières années avec sur un dossier
650000 € avant que ça parte d'ailleurs à
l'étranger Belgique ou encore récemment
120000 € sur un trafic de de stupéfiant
à planté au Tarteret une grosse cité de
lesess alors juste pour ajouter c'est
des équipes qui font de l'économie donc
nous on a constaté sur nos dernières
affaires ils font du flux tendu pour la
marchandise on stock plus de la
marchandise on la dispatche en moins de
24 heures on Moné de stupéfiron de
hchich depuis le Maroc et dispatché en
quelques heures au clients et pour
l'argent sur le dossier dont parlait
Monsieur le Directeur toutes les
semaines voir tous les 3 4 jours garde
plus de liquidité on on la transmet
immédiatement au au réseau de
blanchiment en région parisienne où on
l' fait repartir de façon un peu
artisanale en Espagne ou au Maroc mais
on pendant perquisition constate qu'ils
ne veulent plus stocker d'argent par
rapport à la police par rapport au
concurrents aussi c aussi des fois ils
ont des désagrément de se faire voler
leur magot on va dire par les
concurrents mais ils font vraiment du
flux tendu donc nous c'est une
difficulté pour saisir du numéraire on
sait que ça va être compliqué parce que
ils veulent surtout pas le garder les
les acquisitions de fond de commerce
avec un chiffre d'affaires fictif un
dépôt de bilan puis une revente espèce
de caroussel c'est quelque chose que
vous avez identifié les
ongleries les magasins de téléphonie
mobile
les la restauration
rapide c'est quelque chose que vous avez
identifié vous avez repéré pour blanchir
alors pas nécessairement des ongleries
choses comme ça mais oui des achats je
vous cit
barachicha des kebabs des choses comme
ça effectivement qui sont des des
deventures des des des lessiveuses come
pour dire pour parler un peu cruent
absolument ouais et selon vous un
travail avec les GREPES des tribunaux de
commerce et qui pourrait travailler de
manière plus étroite avec Tracfin pour
identifier ces sessions répétitives
parce qu'en fait si on a bien compris le
délinquant achète un fond de commerce et
un faux chiffre d'affaires on travaille
pendant 8 mois on paye en espèce ce qui
est faisable quand on est sous les
seuils prévu par la législation et puis
ensuite on dépose le bilan puis on
rachète le fond et on fait
ça régulièrement selon vous le recours
au tribunaux de commerce des
informations par les tribunaux de
commerce ça serait quelque chose d'utile
euh je je suis pas un spécialiste mais
je pense que dans le cadre de leurs
investigations que ce soit les Gires
travaillent déjà en relation làdus ouiou
absolument ils on ils ont détecté
effectivement ce C espèce vulnérabilité
dans les montages on a une présence
obligato malgré ça il y a une activité
illicite qui est très
importante sur les observation sur le
sujet excusez-moi le début de votre
phrase a été coupé
question le le le blanchiment à travers
l'acquisition de fonds de commerce alors
ils sont typés je parlais des ongleries
euh des barachicha de la restauration
rapide de la téléphonie un chiffre
d'affaires fictif qui est constitué par
le blanchiment de cet argent en espèce
un dépôt de bilan et puis une procédure
itérative le fond est
revendu parfois deux fois dans la même
année
est-ce que selon vous c'est quelque
chose qui est identifié qui est connu
qui a été
répertorié sur les son oui ça été
identifié réper sur les son
effectivement ce sont principalement les
GIR qui travaill trava sur ce type de
société en collaboration avec les
services équipes qui TR sur St pour
pouvoir associer en fait les
investigations est-ce qu'il une
observation une remarque ou un point que
vous souhaitiez amener qui ne serait pas
sorti de nos questions nos
échanges bon ben écoutez on va très
chaleureusement vous remercier pour
votre contribution et
puis ou on est on était un peu un peu à
la Bour donc désolé pour ce retard à
l'allumage merci beaucoup messieur merci
merci à
vousoir